domination countdown clock is ticking in
24 hours president trump will announce
his pick to replace the late just
justice ruth bader ginsburg on the
supreme court now judge amy coney
barrett is considered to be the heavy
front-runner
here's what the president said about the
big decision just last night
on saturday i will be announcing my
nominee to the united states supreme
court
be a very talented person it will be a
woman i'm sorry man
it will be a woman if given power biden
and his supporters would pack the court
you know they're talking about packing
the court
because we have won racism we have one
but they want to pack the court you know
that means they want to put on a lot of
justices these are things that are just
horrible
i guess we could do that too right and
now when it seems as though republicans
are winning the supreme court battle
democrats are trying to
change the rules they are reportedly
planning to unveil a new bill limiting
the number of supreme court justices a
president can appoint and how long those
justices can serve
and is impeachment still an option well
here's what nancy pelosi is now saying
i don't think he's worth the trouble at
this point we have 40 days until the
election
he is trying to discredit mail-in voting
which is hurting as you've heard some of
the republicans say
this has been an important part of our
electoral success
all right maybe we start with you jesse
about the announcement tomorrow i mean
this is a big moment this is the this
will be the third supreme court justice
that president trump has had the
opportunity to nominate in his first
term
it's pretty remarkable yes in waters
world we'll be covering it live
saturday night we have the rally and the
announcement at five o'clock so greg
will be home
i will be live
but um listen the democrats
they might get lucky because half the
time republican presidents
they get up to the tee box and they just
shank one you could have a david suter
you could have a kennedy you know you
could have roberts
sometimes they nominate swing justices
or liberal justices
so you know statistically she could be a
total bust but she won't because i've
looked into her record
thoroughly dana yes she does has a very
long paper trail
and i think a lot of people think that
she's going to be a very uh originalist
uh when she interprets the constitution
she clerked for scalia and she has
writings that really reveal her thinking
uh the democrats are now saying they're
going to not
go to the hearings they're saying
they're going to try to destroy her
character
so that she becomes unfit and make the
process look like a sham
they're acting completely childish but
it doesn't look good and here's why
this weekend the news is going to
dominate that she's the pick
we believe then on monday we're hearing
that another shoe is going to drop on
the russia investigation some documents
that are going to be
released on tuesday you have the debate
that might not go
too well for sleepy joe wednesday comey
is probably gonna get his head kicked in
by the senate committee and then on
friday you're gonna have the jobs report
from september
while president trump is campaigning and
stoking
a lot of energy all over the country
biden's not doing any of that so
next couple days it could be bad for
democrats
all right we'll see of course we'll see
what happens there's a prominent
democrat who had something to
say about this greg listen to this one
this is hillary clinton
this could not be more diabolical and i
think
that democrats need to be absolutely
clear
any vote for any republican is literally
a vote to cost you money
uh to make your health care more
expensive and maybe to eliminate the
possibility you'll be able to afford it
at all didn't obamacare make health care
more expensive uh
kinda yeah she's very she's kind of
evolving into a female version of dr
evil like she just shows up now on every
issue she should be holding a little
hairless cat
just sitting there because she said and
then she just and there's no way you can
listen to her because she doesn't sound
reasonable because she's bitter and
angry for four years doesn't this look
good when you're doing this you're with
your hand there's a cat here
all right to your point i didn't know
this that the dem said they weren't
going to show up at the hearing
i agree with them they shouldn't show up
this is gonna sail right through
they got the votes don't go that'll save
us so much time
we won't have to cover it on the five we
won't have to sit here and go what are
we gonna say about this crap because we
see it all the time
if the gems don't show up the
republicans don't have to show up they
have the vote everything's great
so i think that's awesome and also to
your point about you were
complaining about the uh the judge's
appointed uh suitor and roberts
what you're pointing out is an
interesting thing republican judges are
less ideological
than democrats yeah i mean i think i
think that's actually not
a bad thing now what's going to happen
though with the democrats is they're
going to go
after uh amy amy what's her name coney
amy coney barrett
coney okay uh uh for her um
religion and they're gonna portray her
religion as extreme
because she actually adheres to it and
the people that will be going after her
will be praising
joe biden a you know person who's prided
for his catholicism as a pro-abortionist
not pro-abortionist but pro-abortion
he's not an abortion he's pro-choice
he's pro-choice that's what we call it
yes but i'm not part of the we so uh
anyway so
i want to do an analogy if you are going
after her
from his position that's like playing in
the minors and making fun of somebody
playing in the pros
because this person actually lives what
she's preaching and you're just in the
bush league
pretending to be something but because
for for interest of power you're
you know you're you're not pro-life but
i don't want to leak the news i think
that
i just got word that the gg show is
expanding to two hours
uh working back at nine o'clock because
the judge might not be there
oh yeah oh i heard that i didn't i know
those world sources
have told me the similar things wow is
really hey so
you brought up the litmus test on
religion and mark meadows the chief of
staff talked about that earlier today
let's take a listen
they're coming after their faith their
catholic faith and uh
if they're going to go after a judge
based on what they believe
not on how they voted and not based on
their record
shame on them that shouldn't be a litmus
test for the court
katie thoughts on that well it proves
that the left
takes what your personal life is in
terms of what they think you should be
doing in your decisions on the supreme
court so they think that if you're a
pro-life catholic in your private life
then you would
automatically rule in in reversal of roe
v
wade because they think that if you were
a pro-choice or pro-abortion
uh candidate that you should be in favor
of keeping roe v wade so they think that
your personal
behavior should bleed into your
decisions whereas i would say
conservatives and republicans think that
you should be reading the constitution
as it is written and applied the laws
that congress passes rather than
allowing your personal
preferences on religion or other issues
to kind of bleed into what your
decisions would be
but in terms of how democrats are
playing this here again it all comes
down to double
standards what greg said about joe biden
being catholic that's
that's fine for him to be faithful and
to have different opinions
about his personal life than he would
implement as president or the policy
positions that he holds but it's not
okay for
a woman like amy coney barrett who has
lived her life as a catholic
who has maybe a different view on
abortion than joe biden does when it
comes to
public policy who said now that
taxpayers actually should pay
for abortions that's not okay for her
i also find this attack on her religion
and her community they are kind of
trying to portray it as a sexist
community that doesn't support women
being
in careers outside of raising their
children
this is a woman who is about to be
appointed possibly
a supreme court justice and there is no
doubt that her community
has supported her in her ambitions as a
mother she has many children two of them
adopted
and as a woman who has pursued her legal
career and so i think that the double
standard there
for a liberal woman they would be
celebrating her as breaking the glass
ceiling again
and being someone who should be
celebrated for being in a place where
men have dominated
well don't hold your breath because
that's probably not going to happen how
do you think the democrats are
positioned jessica
i don't think we're positioned
particularly well on this nomination
once mitt romney came out and said that
he was going to
vote for the president's nominee not
even knowing who it was going to be
i kind of packed up my proverbial bags
and said we've got to focus on winning
the election because stephen breyer is
82 years old
i wrote about this for foxnews.com i
essentially am treating rbg
seat as gone and saying we're going to
be at 6
30 and we need to make sure that we're
not going to be at 7-2
as we move forward and i think that
democrats need to hone in
on one particular argument and i i have
greg's cat here
and it was exactly what hillary clinton
was talking about and
when i listened to jesse's fantasy week
which i hope
next week looks nothing like you think
it will what you didn't mention
is that we will lose thousands more
american lives to coronavirus and that
is the number one issue
to american voters who are going to the
polls it was in 2018
healthcare and now it's about the
handling of covet and healthcare
and the aaca is on the line and a litmus
test that people
are looking for republicans in terms of
justice
is how they feel about the affordable
care act and if you listen to someone
like josh hawley
who says you know my test is roe v wade
we need to repeal and replace
trump says we need to repeal and replace
he comes out with that you know
faux plan yesterday that was just you
seniors please come back to me i know
that you like joe biden
more than me you look at that and you
say democrats need to make the case to
the american public
if you want health care and you want
your pre-existing conditions protected
joe biden is your choice on november 3rd
well
we will see what happens but doesn't it
so i would say that all makes sense but
then doesn't that
completely undermine the whole idea of
identity politics well but this is about
jessica
that you nominate a woman but you know
somebody has a very reasonable democrat
and
more people should listen to it but that
know what my point is overall
it doesn't matter who you nominate
gender
wise that's my point it does and the
representation matters then you should
support it it did with sandra day
o'connor though and ruth bader ginsburg
who was very close to her and talked
lovingly about her and her impact on
ginsburg's ability to
you know really come into her own on the
court and to be welcomed there
so i i don't i don't buy that it's not
that wait until the hearings start and
you'll be
there and i'm going to say that i think
that the democrats
will show up at the hearing jesse
because all of them are auditioning
for the primary in 2020. they're getting
a lot of pressure not to show up so
we'll see
and i can't believe you called her a
reasonable democrat she's
hey so much street cred